Maltese ships in cross yeah okay yes oh
no you just say Chris I challenge you to
rap about three things to three things
okay being raised by wolves yeah
breeding different varieties of dogs
yeah public urination cool lovely this
gonna be a freestyle about all those
things
enjoy yep lie in here in the hall wait
Charlie dog got a rep for you to day I'm
gonna say thinks in in your home slip in
on the parquet chewing on a bone shittin
in the park hey that is what I do find a
little lamppost and just go through I
urinate and I cut my leg but you were
lady dog
so you squat instead you don't like to
lift your little pelvis you don't want
to shake like your name Elvis but you're
one thing that I must discuss you're a
mixer dog that means you are a
ma-ma-ma-ma-machine a breed bread
together
which one was your father I don't know
it would cause a pallava to go into that
kind of art as we Raptor there be other
Snoop Dogg yeah one day you might be on
their telly I do a little rap as I'm
rubbing your belly
you're not smelly cuz you get a shampoo
every week raised in by our wolves men
it's hard to speak here and if you're
raised by them you might need this to
remember back Romulus and Remus yo they
were raised by wolves in the home and
then later founded as to equal Rome and
Aunt Bea like flame what you mean if we
must had founded it it would be called
dream that would be a real dream for him
it's so fun to discuss the and then to
begin an often I find such frustration
you're a dog so it's fine for public
urination but for me I need to find an
ally and if I get caught by the police
they'd be like yo you cannot urinate
there because my body and my legs are
covered in hair if I was a little
you know what never failed I poo on the
Daily Mail and working my tail Beshara
was happy but I would never wear a nappy
I want to let my poo go free just be
crappy anywhere and it gets picked up by
my own I've been like doh yeah like his
Homer Homer also did an ancient tale
link it back to Romulus and Remus never
fail Charlie you don't don't seem very
excited may have just freestyles